etonnant non les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire 5ème 6ème bientôt septième
chaîne
rassurez vous il y en aura pas 8 il ya
passé deux frères seydoux en tout cas la
pluri télévision- it est inéluctable
alors calmos et comme disait attila à
sainte geneviève
prenons un peu de recul sinon comment
veux-tu passé le premier moment de
saintes fureur et la première réaction
salutaire de rejet posons-nous
paisiblement la question cette cinquième
chaîne qui nous pend à l'antenne sera
t-elle vraiment ce dépotoir haï débat ce
que nous redoutons temps où des brutes
italo wisigothe assoiffés de lire vont
venir jusque dans nos bras pour
charcuter nos bobine est décimée nos
pellicule sous un torrent de réclames
signer phobique sans vouloir me faire le
chantre des lessiviers et encore moins
la coloc démarche en dessous j'ai même
pu finir la mienne il m'apparaît à la
réflexion que ce projet de cinquième
chaîne ne manque pas d'un certain charme
d'abord ça va faire chier les cinéphiles
et quiconque est susceptible de faire du
mal un cinéphile ne saurait être tout à
fait mauvais dirait leur idole le
méchant monsieur fils qui sont ils
les cinéphiles sinon ces poussières aux
ectoplasmes de la culture dans le noir
qui glisse gonflé de suffisance au
dessus du populaire sur le nuage opaque
de leurs réseaux terrisse mme leur
cerveau presbytes recroquevillé dans la
naphtaline ne les autorise à comprendre
que par le petit bout de leur
entendement réactionnaire ça ne cesse
bouddhique sur l'abscons ça ne réalise
qu'un retardement
quand de funès est mort qu'il avait le
génie de jerry lewis ça fait semblant de
cause et anglais et d'après mon beau
frère qui fait dans les tubes à
l'institut pasteur s'est pourvue de
quéquette trop petit pour attraper le
sida sens at-elle
[Applaudissements]
on va nous entrecouper les films de
spots publicitaires et alors comme
dirait le pen soyons clairs il y a deux
sortes de films les bons et les mauvais
d'accord non le problème avec les bons
avec les bons films à la télévision
c'est qu'on est vissé dans son fauteuil
sans aucune possibilité d'échappatoire
de crainte d'en manquer la moindre image
désormais grâce à la pub on va pouvoir
se lever pour un pipi salubre pour aller
chercher les pistaches dans la cuisine
ou pour finir le char à la hache
quant aux mauvais film plus relais
charcute plus ont fait oeuvre utile non
quelle fourbe qu'elle sournois qu'elle
demeurait quel cinéphile oserait
soutenir le contraire il faut également
savoir que la cinquième chaîne en
dépoussiérant les trains trains va faire
souffrir les trois premières pour
l'heure des hordes avachi de fossiles
comateux collabore à la prospérité de la
ringardise syndicaux administrative dans
nos trois chaînes d'état dans la torpeur
immuable de leur incompétence ronds de
cuir c'est cachalots échoués barbotte re
plaide médiocrité dans la boue tiède de
leur inefficacité
la seule pensée de voir passer une idée
neuve les plombs sous leur bureau
certes le pétomane et chantal goya ne
s'en plaigne guerre mais d'autres et
j'en connais qui crèvent de faim dans
leur sous pente avec leur chien maigre
et leur talent censuré ne manqueront pas
de se réjouir simplement de la mise à la
retraite anticipée de ces potentats mou
au fait j'ai croisé l'autre soir dans un
restaurant le fameux italien maudit et
il allait le front haut cerné de pépiant
de groupies qui chassait l'autographe je
veux dire qu'ils aient trouvé plutôt
sympa berlusconi et c'est berlusconi est
membre
[Musique]